Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. From early morning workouts that need a boost to late night drives that need vibes, a good playlist can help you make the most out of your everyday. And when it comes to everyday spending, you can count on the PC Insider's World Elite MasterCard to help you earn the most PC optimum points everywhere you shop. With the best playlists, you never miss a good song.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、剧集抢先听，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。从需要注入活力的清晨锻炼，到需要情绪氛围的深夜驾车，一份好的播放列表能帮您充分利用每一天。而在日常消费方面，您可以信赖 PC  Insider's World Elite 万事达卡，它能帮您在购物时赚取最多的 PC Optimum 积分。有了最棒的播放列表，您绝不会错过任何一首好歌。
With this card, you never miss out on getting the most points on everyday purchases. The PC Insider's World Elite MasterCard. The card for living unlimited. Conditions apply to all benefits. Visit pcfinancial.ca for details. In a certain reign, whose can it have been? Someone of no great rank, among all his Majesty's consorts and intimates enjoyed exceptional favor. Those others who had always assumed that pride of place was properly theirs despised her as a dreadful woman, while the lesser intimates were unhappier still.
持有这张卡，您在日常消费中绝不会错过赚取最多积分的机会。PC Insider's World Elite 万事达卡。畅享无限生活的信用卡。各项福利均受条款约束。详情请访问 pcfinancial.ca。在某一个朝代，会是谁的统治呢？在所有陛下的妃嫔和近侍中，有一位出身并不显赫的女子，备受恩宠。其他那些理所当然认为自己地位尊崇的人，都鄙视她是个可怕的女性，而那些地位较低的近侍则更加心怀不满。
The way she waited on him day after day only stirred up feeling against her, and perhaps this growing burden of resentment was what affected her health and obliged her often to withdraw in misery to her home. But His Majesty, who could less and less do without her, ignored his critics until his behaviour seemed bound to be the talk of all. So that is the opening paragraph of the supreme, unchallenged, canonical classic of Japanese literature. It's a novel called The Tale of Genji. And to give you a sense of the sheer weight of it, in the translation by Royal Tyler,
她日复一日地伺候他，只招致了更多对她的怨恨，也许这不断增加的怨恨积压影响了她的健康，迫使她常常痛苦地退居家中。但陛下越来越离不开她，对批评置之不理，直到他的行为似乎注定要成为所有人的谈资。这就是日本文学中至高无上、无可撼动、奉为圭臬的经典之作的开篇段落。这是一部名为《源氏物语》的小说。为了让您对它的宏大体量有个概念，在罗伊·泰勒（Roy Tyler）的译本中，
which we'll be quoting from a fair bit today. That book is more than 1000 pages long. Now, Tom, we're not the rest is literature. So what is a Japanese novel doing on a history podcast? Please explain. Two answers. So as you said, this is the great classic of Japanese literature. I guess the obvious parallel might be with Don Quixote and the role that it plays in Spain. I mean, maybe even with the plays of Shakespeare in England.
我们今天也会引用其中相当一部分内容。这本书有一千多页长。那么，汤姆，我们可不是《文学的余烬》。所以，一部日本小说为什么会出现在一个历史播客里呢？请解释一下。两个答案。正如你所说，这是日本文学的伟大经典。我想一个显而易见的平行对比可能是《堂吉诃德》及其在西班牙扮演的角色。我的意思是，甚至可能类似于莎士比亚的戏剧在英国的地位。
And I will quote the novelist who in 1968 won Japan's first Nobel Prize for Literature, Yasunari Kawabata in his acceptance speech. And he described it as the highest pinnacle of Japanese literature. And as a Nobel Prize winner, I mean, he would absolutely know. He's not wrong. It's had a massive influence, right? It's had an influence all through Japanese culture on anime and manga and all kinds of tales. Right the way up to the present day, but going all the way back through medieval Japan because
我将引用一位小说家的话，他在1968年获得了日本第一个诺贝尔文学奖——川端康成在获奖感言中的话。他将这部作品描述为日本文学的最高巅峰。作为一名诺贝尔奖得主，我的意思是，他绝对对此心知肚明。他没有说错。它产生了巨大的影响，对吧？它对整个日本文化都产生了影响，包括动漫、漫画和各种故事。一直延续到今天，并且一直追溯到日本的中世纪，因为
this novel is by the standards of the Western novel, I mean, unbelievably ancient. So it's written in the early years of the 11th century, and it has profoundly, profoundly shaped the Japanese sense of what it is to be Japanese. So it's kind of a historical artifact in its own right. Mm hmm. But I think also it opens an absolutely brilliant window onto what is often described as the classical age of Japan, the first great golden age, 10th and 11th centuries in Japan. And this is a Japan that is emerging for the first time, really, as a distinctive civilization. So it's long existed in the shadow of China, but this kind of cultural cringe that it had long had, it's got rid of, it is expressing ideals of
以西方小说的标准来看，这部小说简直古老得不可思议。它是写于11世纪初，它深刻地、极大地塑造了日本人的“日本性”观念。所以它本身就是一种历史文物。嗯。但我也认为，它为我们打开了一扇极其精彩的窗口，让我们得以一窥常被描述为日本古典时代的光景——日本的第一个黄金时代，即10th和11世纪。这是一个真正开始作为独特文明首次崛起的日本。所以它长期生活在中国的阴影之下，但它长期以来拥有的这种文化自卑感已经烟消云散，它正在表达
kind of beauty and grace that will again run throughout Japanese history. And to be honest, if you're a historian of say ancient or medieval history, to read it is quite a mind blowing experience because you are being given an insider's vision of an imperial court that is much, much richer, I think, than anything that we have from, I don't know, ancient Egypt or Mesopotamia or Persia or Rome or Baghdad or even China. And I've just been to Japan. I read it while I was in Japan. And I have to say it was one of the great
某种美与优雅的理想，这些理想将贯穿整个日本历史。说实话，如果你是一位古代或中世纪历史学家，阅读它将是一次令人大开眼界的体验，因为你将获得对一个帝国宫廷的内部视角，这个视角比我们所拥有的来自——我不知道——古埃及、美索不达米亚、波斯、罗马、巴格达甚至中国的任何记录都要丰富得多、深刻得多。我刚刚去过日本。我在日本的时候读了它。我必须说，这是我人生中绝佳的
Reading experiences of my life. Well, Tom, I know when you say something like that You genuinely mean it because the only other book that I've heard you say those words about the only other moment I've heard you talk about with the same Sort of respect and even dare I say or mmm was the chapter on snooker in my book who dares wins? No, not just the chapter on snooker Dominic book who dares wins. No, not just the chapter on snooker Dominic, the whole vast tone. Wow. And I would say that who dares wins your great book on the first two years of the Thatcher government, even longer than the tale of Genji.
阅读体验之一。好吧，汤姆，我知道当你这样说时，你是真心实意的，因为我听过你用这种词评价的唯一另一本书，我听过你用这种尊重甚至可以说是敬畏的语气谈论的唯一另一个时刻，就是我的书《谁敢获胜》中关于斯诺克的章节。不，不仅仅是斯诺克章节，多米尼克的书《谁敢获胜》。不，不仅仅是斯诺克章节，多米尼克，而是整部宏大的著作。哇。而且我要说，《谁敢获胜》——你关于撒切尔政府前两年的伟大著作——甚至比《源氏物语》还要长。
I think in a thousand years time will be looked back on with similar or I mean, Tom, that's really kind of you. You're obviously not the first person I've heard that from. And it probably won't be the last, but it's lovely to hear it all the same. Anyway, you're welcome. Let me just echo what you said. We'll be talking a fair bit about the classics produced during this kind of classical golden age of Japanese culture.
我想一千年后，人们回看它时也会带着类似的……我的意思是，汤姆，你真是太好了。你显然不是第一个对我说这话的人。这大概也不会是最后一个，但听到这话还是很开心。无论如何，不客气。我也附和一下你的话。我们接下来要讨论相当一部分在这个日本文化的古典黄金时代创作的经典作品。
And I have to say, you know, I was a little bit suspicious when you first mentioned this subject and then I started reading them and my mind was blown. I couldn't believe that this was being produced in the same period as the Anglo-Saxons were kind of, you know, smashing each other on the head with mallets or whatever. They're amazing, aren't they? So we're going to use this as a window into Japanese history and culture. But before we do that, let's get back to the novel itself and actually let's
我必须说，你知道的，当你第一次提到这个话题时，我其实有点怀疑，但当我开始阅读它们时，我整个人都被震撼了。我简直不敢相信，这竟然是与盎格鲁-撒克逊人挥舞着木槌互相砸脑袋的同一时期产出的作品。它们太惊人了，不是吗？所以我们将以此作为深入了解日本历史和文化的一扇窗户。但在我们这样做之前，让我们先回到小说本身，实际上让我们
kick off with that first paragraph that I opened with. So the stuff about the consorts and intimates and his majesty and all of that stuff. So unpack that a little bit for us. What's all that about? Well, I mean, there are kind of various pointers to the character of the Japanese court in this period, even in that opening paragraph. So we have this emperor, but he's not named. I mean, he seems peculiarly anonymous. And he's in the early 11th century, just to be clear. So the 10 hundreds, the tale of Genji is actually a historical novel.
从我开篇提到的那个第一段开始切入。也就是关于妃嫔、近侍、陛下以及所有这些内容的部分。所以请为我们剖析一下。这到底是怎么回事？好吧，我的意思是，即使在那个开篇段落中，也有各种暗示那个时期日本宫廷特征的线索。这里出现了一位天皇，但他没有名字。我的意思是，他显得格外匿名。而且要明确的是，故事发生在11世纪初。也就是1000年代，《源氏物语》实际上是一部历史小说。
So it's set in the 10th century. Okay. So the nine hundreds. Yeah. We're told who's, you know, whose reign can it have been? It's deliberately anonymous. He clearly has a kind of harem. There seemed to be two orders of women.
所以它的背景设定在10th世纪。好吧。也就是900年代。是的。我们被告知，这是“谁的统治呢？”这是故意匿名的。他显然拥有某种后宫。那里似乎有两级女性。
So there are consorts who are clearly higher ranking and then there are intimates who seem to be slightly lower. And the emperor, he's obsessed by a low ranking intimate, and this is clearly offending court etiquette, but he's pursuing the affair anyway. And I mean, anyone who's read, you know, the Arabian Nights or something like that will feel that it's it's the kind of story in which this intimate is going to get pregnant and give birth to a prince. This will set the whole dynamics of the of the story and trade.
所以有地位明显更高的妃嫔，然后是有地位略低的近侍。而这位天皇，他痴迷于一位地位低下的近侍，这显然触犯了宫廷礼仪，但他还是不顾一切地继续这段私情。我的意思是，任何读过《一千零一夜》之类作品的人都会觉得，这是一个这样的故事：这位近侍将会怀孕并生下一位王子。这将奠定整个故事的戏剧动力和走向。
Of course. And initially, it seems that this is the kind of book that we're reading because it only takes three more paragraphs before the intimate is indeed pregnant by the emperor and she delivers him a son. And you know, as would happen in any kind of folk tale, the baby turns out to be kind of luminously good looking. So to quote from the tale of Genji, his majesty had the child brought in straight away for he was desperate to see him and he was astonished by his beauty.
当然。起初，这似乎正是我们正在阅读的那种书，因为仅仅过了三个段落，这位近侍果然怀上了天皇的孩子，并为他生下一个儿子。你知道的，正如任何民间故事中会发生的那样，这个婴儿生下来就散发着夺目的光芒。引用《源氏物语》中的话说：陛下立刻让人把孩子抱过来，因为他渴望见到他，并为他的美貌大吃一惊。
His elder son, born to his consort, the daughter of the minister of the right, enjoyed powerful backing and was fated by all as the undoubted future heir apparent. But he could not rival his brother in looks and his majesty who still accorded the heir apparent all due respect nevertheless lavished his private affection on the new arrival. So that really is fairy tale stuff. You've got the older brother who's going to be the next emperor and the younger brother who's obviously much nicer and better looking who's sort of put down in some way because of his inferior background. Right. So you feel that you know the rules of the game. The Emperor dotes on this kind of beautiful younger son, but he knows that it's impossible
他的长子是右大臣的女儿、妃嫔所生，享有强大的后盾，所有人都认定他无疑是未来的储君。但他却无法在相貌上与弟弟匹敌，而依然给予储君应有尊重的陛下，却将自己私下的宠爱倾注在这个新降生的孩子身上。所以这真的是童话般的情节。你有了将成为下一任天皇的哥哥，以及显然更讨人喜欢、长相更好看的弟弟，因为其较低的背景而在某种程度上受到压制。没错。所以你觉得你懂这个游戏的规则。天皇溺爱这个美丽的幼子，但他知道这是不可能的
to appoint him as his heir because the intimate is not of sufficient social standing. The boy grows up, he becomes ever more handsome, so much so that his nickname is the Shining Prince. And as well as being stunningly handsome, he has incredible dress sense, you know, amazing style but also luminous talents. And in due course, he will be renowned for his genius as a poet, as a musician, as a calligrapher, as a mixer of incense, all these great qualities that are fated at the Imperial Court.
立他为储君，因为这位近侍的社会地位不够高。男孩长大后，变得越来越英俊，以至于他的绰号是“光源氏”。除了惊人的美貌，他还有着不可思议的穿衣品味——惊人的时尚感，同时还有着耀眼的天赋。不久之后，他就以其在诗歌、音乐、书法、香料调制方面的天才而闻名，所有这些在宫廷中备受赞誉的卓越品质他都具备。
And he's even good at football Which is described in the novel as a rough game, but lively and requiring skill. Crikey, who knew? Yeah, I didn't know that. Who knew the Japanese played football? That cannot be right Tom. Does everybody not know that it was invented in our great public schools? This is shocking. I'm not entirely sure what the rules were, but it clearly involved kicking a ball. Right.
而且他甚至很擅长踢蹴鞠。小说中将其描述为一项粗野但充满活力且需要技巧的运动。天哪，谁能想到呢？是的，我以前不知道。谁能想到日本人还会踢球？这绝对不对，汤姆。难道不是所有人都知道这是在我们伟大的公学里发明的吗？这太令人震惊了。我不太确定规则是什么，但它显然涉及踢球。没错。
So this younger son, he's very very talented and his father is desperate that he doesn't waste his potential because the problem is, is that if he just remains a prince, the emperor worries that he'll be a kind of drone because he will never get to inherit the throne. And so the emperor takes a drastic step. He officially removes the boy from the imperial family and he does this by giving the boy what no emperor ever has, namely a surname. And the surname the boy is given is Genji. And as a Genji, he now belongs to two realms. So the realm of his father's palace, the great center of
所以这个小儿子非常有才华，他的父亲极其渴望他不浪费自己的潜力，因为问题在于，如果他仅仅停留在亲王的位置上，天皇会担心他会变成某种“废物”，因为他永远无法继承皇位。于是天皇采取了激进的一步。他正式将这个男孩从皇室中除名，通过给予这个男孩一个前所未有、即从未有过的皇室成员所没有的姓氏。男孩被赐予的姓氏是“源氏”。作为一个源氏，他现在属于两个领域。一方面是他父亲的宫殿、伟大的
Japanese Imperial life, but also the realm of the nobility who provide the great public figures who serve the palace. And the novel of which he is the hero, the tale of Genji, is in large part the story of how he negotiates these ambivalences, his role as a prince who is kind of simultaneously a nobleman, one of the great kind of ministerial figures of the court. Okay. So you set up the boy.
日本宫廷生活的中心，另一方面也是提供服务于宫廷的伟大公众人物的贵族阶层。而他是其中主角的小说——《源氏物语》——在很大程度上就是关于他如何协调这些双重身份的故事，他既是一位亲王，同时又是一位贵族，是宫廷中重要的内阁重臣之一。好了。你已经铺垫了这个男孩。
Now let's talk a little bit about the world. So anybody who knows anything about Japanese history and culture or who, for example, has played the new Assassin's Creed video game or has seen the TV series Shogun will have a sense automatically of the world that Genji is moving through. So you know, there's the amazing temples, there's the samurai, there are people taking their own life because they've been humiliated in some way. Yeah, Bushido, the warrior code, all of that, all of that stuff. But this is all rubbish, right?
现在我们来谈谈这个世界。所以，任何对日本历史和文化略知一二的人，或者例如玩过最新的《刺客信条》电子游戏，或者看过电视剧《幕府将军》的人，都会自动对源氏所处的世界有一种感觉。你知道的，有惊人的寺庙，有武士，有因为某种原因感到受辱而自寻短见的人。是的，武士道，武士准则，所有这些，所有这些东西。但这些全都是无稽之谈，对吧？
This isn't operating at this time. Right. Because the tale of Genji is much earlier than all that. Right. And to be honest, it's earlier than all that right and to be honest It's older than kind of most of the traditions that I guess in in the minds I people have about medieval Japan. So samurai no samurai. No samurai geishas No, no geisha no sushi. No sushi shocking. No kabuki. I mean none of that people drinking tea surely There's people drinking tea. There probably is people drinking tea. Yes.
这些在当时并不存在。对的。因为《源氏物语》比这一切都要早得多。没错。说实话，它比这一切都要早得多，而且老实说
I'm not absolutely sure about that, but I think there probably is. Let's pretend that there is just for the purposes of the podcast. I mean, certainly eating rice. Okay. But I mean, this is just a measure of how old it is. And you said how extraordinary it is, is that this is the same time as all the events we were describing in our series on 1066. The tale of Genji is being written while in England, Ethelred the Unready is busy
它比人们心目中关于中世纪日本的大多数传统都要古老。所以，没有武士。没有武士。没有艺伎。没有，没有艺伎。没有寿司。没有寿司，太令人震惊了。没有歌舞伎。我的意思是，完全没有这些。人们喝茶吧，肯定有人喝茶。应该有人喝茶。
extorting silver to pay off the Vikings. I mean just imagine if you had a novel written by the Anglo-Saxons, a thousand pages long, that gave you such an amazing window. God, historians would be sobbing with joy if that such a thing existed. It's unbelievable. But it kind of couldn't have existed because Anglo-Saxon society didn't have the conditions for it to exist, right? But Japanese society does. Right. So in Europe, I guess the first novel of modern Europe is Don Quixote. So, Tale of Genji is 600 years older than that, is 700 years older than Robinson Crusoe, which is generally thought to be the first English novel. It's often called the world's oldest novel. It's not strictly speaking because the Greeks and the Romans had fictions written in prose, but I think it is indisputably,
我对此不是百分之百确定，但我想可能有的。我们就假装有，纯粹为了播客的效果。我的意思是，肯定有吃米饭。好吧。但这只是它有多古老的一个衡量标准。正如你所说它有多么非凡，这是与我们在关于1066年的系列节目中所描述的所有事件发生在同一时期的。在英国的“失国者”埃塞尔雷德正忙于
as Raoul Terrel, whose translation we're using, describes it in his introduction, the oldest novel still widely recognized today as a masterpiece. But for all the reasons that you're touching on the fact that you are getting a glimpse into such a distant, alien, ancient world, to me, it seemed one of the most extraordinary works of literature that I'd ever read. I mean, and obviously, I don't speak Japanese. I'm not familiar with Japanese history at all. So, you know, Keats writing about, you know, he couldn't speak Greek and then he comes across this translation by Chapman and he talks, doesn't he, about being like Stout Cortez with eagle eyes staring at the Pacific on him.
勒索白银来收买维京人时，《源氏物语》正在被撰写。试想一下，如果你有一部由盎格鲁-撒克逊人写的小说，有一千页长，为你提供了这样一扇神奇的窗口。天哪，如果真有这样的东西存在，历史学家们会幸福得痛哭流涕的。这简直不可思议。但它在某种程度上是不可能存在的，因为盎格鲁-撒克逊社会没有让它存在的条件，对吧？但日本社会却具备。没错。所以，在欧洲，我想现代欧洲的第一部小说是《堂吉诃德》。因此，《源氏物语》比它早了600年，比被普遍认为是第一部英国小说的《鲁滨逊漂流记》早了700年。它通常被称为世界上最古老的小说。严格来说不算，因为希腊人和罗马人也有用散文写成的小说，但我认为它毫无争议地——
Yeah. I mean, I felt a bit like that, that this was a glimpse into a world that I had never imagined seeing and it's incredible. And it's a bit like, I don't know, discovering that somebody had been recording rock and roll in the 14th century. Right. Or that they're being Cubists in Renaissance Florence or something. I mean, it seems weirdly out of time.
正如我们正在使用的译本的译者雷奥·泰勒（Raoul Terrel）在导言中所描述的那样——是至今仍被广泛认为是一部杰作的最古老的小说。但由于你所提到的所有原因——你得以窥见这样一个遥远、异质、古老世界的这一点——对我来说，它似乎是我读过的最非凡的文学作品之一。我的意思是，很明显，我不懂日语。我对日本历史完全不熟悉。所以，你知道的，济慈写到（关于）他不会说希腊语，然后他偶然读到了查普曼的翻译，他谈到——不是吗？——自己就像勇敢的科尔特斯，鹰眼凝视着太平洋……
Yeah. And all the more so when you think about Japan is an island off Eurasia and you think of all the other works of literature that are being produced across Eurasia in this period. So in Persia, you have the great poet Fadawzi is writing the Shahnameh, the great epic of the Iranian people. And this is, it's an epic that has sorcerers and giant talking birds and Alexander the Great and all that kind of stuff. And in Baghdad and Cairo, you're starting to get the Arabian nights in this period.
是的。我的意思是，我当时有点那种感觉，这就像是对一个我从未想象过能看到的世界的惊鸿一瞥，太不可思议了。这有点像，我不知道，发现有人在14th世纪录制摇滚乐一样。对吧。或者文艺复兴时期的佛罗伦萨出现了立体主义画家之类的。我的意思是，这看起来超越时代得不可思议。
And that's all kind of gin and you know, all that. People hiding in vases. All that and in France you have the song of Roland, the story of the great heroic figure in Charlemagne's court who sees off attacking enemies and is kind of presaging the romances of chivalry that will emerge throughout Europe and they're all kind of centered around either the supernatural or masculine heroism or both. But the tale of Genji actually, despite the sense you get from the opening page, actually it's nothing like any of those at all. So you might expect that, you know, he's going to end up fighting a murderous civil war against
是的，当你想到日本是欧亚大陆外海的一个岛屿，并且考虑到在这一时期整个欧亚大陆正在产生的所有其他文学作品时，就更是如此了。所以在波斯，你有伟大的诗人菲尔多西正在撰写《列王纪》，这是伊朗人民伟大的史诗。这是一部有巫师、会说话的巨鸟、亚历山大大帝以及所有诸如此类内容的史诗。在巴格达和开罗，你在这个时期开始有了《一千零一夜》。
his brother or something like that. He doesn't. Yeah. There is no real tension between him and his brother or something like that. He doesn't. There is no real tension between him and his brother whatsoever. He doesn't go around fighting monsters. He doesn't roam the world seeking out adventures. And in fact, aside from a single spell of exile, he spends pretty much his entire life in the Imperial capital in Japan. And the novel is basically about the things he gets up to in the palace and in the
而那里面全都是各种精灵，你知道的，诸如此类。有人藏在罐子里。诸如此类。而在法国，你有《罗兰之歌》，讲述查理曼大帝宫廷中伟大英雄事迹的故事，他击退了进攻的敌人，这预示着将在整个欧洲兴起的骑士传奇，而它们基本上都围绕着超自然现象或阳刚的英雄主义，或者两者兼而有之。但事实上，《源氏物语》尽管你从第一页得到那种感觉，但它实际上与所有这些完全不同。所以你可能会期望，你知道的，他最终会与他的兄弟进行一场你死我活的内战，或者诸如此类的事情。他并没有。是的。他和他的兄弟之间根本没有任何真正的紧张关系。他不会到处去跟怪物战斗。他不会为了寻求冒险而游历世界。事实上，除了有一次短暂的流放经历之外，他几乎把他的一生都花在了日本的帝国都城里。这部小说基本上就是关于他在宫殿和包围它的
city that surrounds it. And there are essentially two things he gets up to. So the first of these, he serves his father as his father had wanted him to as one of the great public servants of Japan. You can trace him going through all the various levels of the imperial bureaucracy. And he begins as a kind of very junior official. And then ultimately he arrives as a kind of honorary retired emperor. Right. You know, he's given this kind of honorary post, he's reintegrated back into the imperial family. And this is tracked in immense detail. So if you are interested in how politics functions in the imperial court, the tale of Genji is absolutely for you. The Anthony Trollope. Exactly, and it's drawn in that kind of detail.
城市里所经历的事情。他主要做两件事。所以其中第一件，他像他父亲所希望的那样，作为日本伟大的公职人员之一来侍奉他的父亲。你可以追踪他历任帝国官僚机构的各个级别。他最初是一个非常低级的官员。最后，他以某种荣誉退休天皇的身份登场。对吧。你知道的，他被授予了这种荣誉职位，重新融入了皇室。这是以极其详尽的细节被追踪记录的。所以如果你对政治在宫廷中是如何运作感兴趣，《源氏物语》绝对适合你。安东尼·特罗洛普式的。没错，正是那种细节。
Right. And that kind of subtlety. And it's a very vivid, very sophisticated portrait of how the Imperial Court actually functioned. You know, what wouldn't a historian of ancient Egypt or... Oh, yeah. He would die for something like that. But the other thing he does, so I will quote from friend of the show, Chris Harding,
没错，还有那种微妙感。这是一幅非常生动、非常复杂的关于帝国宫廷实际运作的肖像。你知道的，古埃及的历史学家会付出什么来换取……噢，是的。他会为了类似这样的东西而死。但另一件事，所以我要引用节目之友克里斯·哈丁（Chris Harding）的话，
who's got a history of Japan that's coming out. I've got sent a preview of it. Yeah, I was reading that last night, would you believe? It's a very good book, a short history of Japan. Yeah. And in it, Chris describes Genji as irrepressibly amorous, which is basically say he's a massive shagger. Right. He never stops. Basically, he only has to see a woman and he's trying to seduce her. And it doesn't matter if the woman is married to the emperor or she's only 12 years old
他有一本关于日本的历史书即将出版。我收到了它的预览版。是的，你敢信，我昨晚就在读那个。这是一本非常好的书，《日本简史》。是的，克里斯在书中将源氏描述为“不可压抑的多情”，这基本上就是说他是一个超级大情圣。没错。他从不罢休。基本上，他只要看到一个女人，就试图去勾引她。而且不管这个女人是天皇的妻子，还是只有12岁，
or she's his ward or she is the daughter of his ex lover. Okay. Or I don't know, the daughter of his best friend, Genji or Parlin. He's all for it. Right. Can't hold him back. Yeah. So he's not very me too.
或者是他的受监护人，或者是他前女友的女儿。好吧。或者我不知道，他最好朋友的女儿，源氏或者帕林。他统统来者不拒。没错。根本拦不住他。是的。所以他非常不“政治正确”（me too）。
I mean, you very much get cancelled today. I was kind of reading up on this because I was kind of interested to see what Japanese feminist critics today think of it and apparently there's a whole trend it's called Genji-Girai which means Genji bashing. I love the image of you reading up on Japanese feminist criticism of the tale of Genji. Just to be clear you're reading up on that in Japanese right? I on that in Japanese, right? I'm afraid I'm not. No, I'm afraid I'm not. But you know, it's the great classic of Japanese literature, so there's plenty in English on the tale of Genji. Of course there is. But the thing about Genji, why he is so fascinating to his character, why the novel is so kind of
我的意思是，他今天要是在世的话绝对会被取消资格（cancelled）。我当时在查阅相关资料，因为我挺有兴趣看看当今的日本女权主义批评家对它作何感想，显然有一个流派叫做 Genji-Girai，意思是“痛骂源氏”。我真喜欢你阅读关于《源氏物语》的日本女权主义批评的画面。为了明确起见，你是用日语阅读那些资料的，对吧？我……呃……用日语阅读那些资料的，对吧？恐怕我不是。不，恐怕我不是。但你知道的，这是日本文学的伟大经典，所以英文中关于《源氏物语》的内容多得是。当然有。但关于源氏的事情——为什么他的性格如此迷人，为什么这部小说如此复杂和微妙——尽管他经常表现得很糟糕，但一千年来，他同时一直充当着日本人的某种——我想——魅力标杆。对吧。我想今天我们可能会称他为一个“性骚扰惯犯”。他是一个非常慷慨、体贴、善良的“性骚扰惯犯”。噢，这真可爱。这难道不是很美好吗？我的意思是，这方面的衡量标准是，他从未抛弃过任何一个被他勾引的女性。
complex and subtle, even while he's often behaving terribly, he has simultaneously served the Japanese for, you know, a thousand years as the kind of, I suppose, the definitive model of charisma. Right. I mean, I suppose today we would call him a sex pest. He's a very generous, caring, kind sex pest. Oh, that's lovely. Isn't that nice? And I mean, the measure of that is that he never abandons a woman who he has seduced.
他不是唐璜。他不会那种“勾引完就甩”的把戏。没错。在他的一生中，他将自己所有的战利品都安置在他拥有的这座宏伟宫殿里，甚至包括那些他不再迷恋的女性，我认为这表明他是独一无二的。他是个多么可爱的男人啊。多么可爱的男人。
He's not a Don Juan. He doesn't kind of seduce and dump. Right. And over the course of his life, he installs all his various conquests in this kind of vast palace that he has, even those he no longer fancies, which I think shows that he's unique. What a lovely man he is. What a lovely man.
而且他极其有魅力，不是吗？难以言喻的魅力。所以我在你的笔记中读到他身上 literalmente 喷了香水。是的。按10th世纪日本的标准，这大概很不寻常吧？还是说其实很常见？嗯，这几乎带有一种超自然的特质。事实上，源氏在大约小说四分之三处去世，接下来的部分
And he's incredibly glamorous, isn't he? Unspeakably glamorous. So I read in your notes that he is literally perfumed. Yes. That's unusual by the standards of sort of 10th century Japan, presumably. Or is it? Well, there's almost a supernatural quality to it. And in fact, Genji dies about three quarters of the way through the novel and it continues
详细描写了他儿子和孙子的所作所为，他们也都带有一种这样的香水味。但源氏绝对是倾倒众生。这几乎具有某种信息素（费洛蒙）的效果。所以他宫殿里的所有女人都想知道：他到底是怎么做到这一点的，仿佛他身上绽放着春天的柳枝？人们就是这样谈论我的。不管怎样，继续。狂抹须后水。对的，没错。而在小说的核心，他有所有这些女人，但其中有一个女性特别重要，是他一生挚爱，他在小说中对她全心全意。她叫紫，紫姬。“紫”的意思是薰衣草。在他与她的关系中，他那令人发指的特质和迷人的特质相互交织。
with details of what his son does and his grandson and they both have this kind of perfumed quality as well. But Genji is absolute knockout. It's kind of almost pheromonal. So all the women in his palace wonder how does he manage to be as though in him blooms opened on spring willow fronds. People talk like that about me. Anyway, continue. Slapping on the aftershave. Yeah, right. And at the heart of the novel, so he has all these women, but there is one woman in particular who is the great love of his life devoted to throughout the novel. And she is called Murasaki, Lady Murasaki. Murasaki means lavender. In his relationship with her, both his appalling qualities and his charming qualities are kind of intermingled.
我认为这就是衡量这部小说心理复杂程度的标准。这不是一部源氏流于脸谱化的小说。他是一个复杂的、有血有肉的心理人物，就像你在托尔斯泰或类似作家笔下遇到的人物完全一样。那么，紫是谁？所以，她和源氏的母亲很像，社会地位并不重要。所以她是一个亲王和一个低位妃嫔所生的女儿。因此她在生活中完全没有任何前途。源氏在她还是个小女孩时就遇到了她，并收养了她。
And I think this is the measure of how psychologically complex this is as a novel. It's not a novel in which Genji is a type. He is a complex living psychological figure in exactly the way that you might meet in a Tolstoy or someone like that. So who is Murasaki? So she rather like Genji's mother, she's socially unimportant. So she's the daughter of a prince by a kind of minor consort. And so she has no prospects at all in life. Genji meets her when she is a young girl and he adopts her.
随后，一些坦率说来令人发指的行为便发生了。那么他为什么要收养她呢？这是因为紫——而且当时她只是个小女孩——让他想起了皇后。而此时，源氏已经勾引了皇后并让她怀了孕，因为皇后让源氏想起了他的母亲。这其中发生的事情可真够多的。相当多。是的。而且没一件好事。
And some frankly appalling behavior then ensues. So why does he want to adopt her? It's because Murasaki, and she's just a girl at this point, reminds him of the Empress. And by this point, Genji has already seduced and got pregnant the Empress because the Empress reminds Genji of his mother. That's a hell of a lot going on there. Quite a lot. Yeah. None of it good.
出于这个相当可疑的原因，源氏对她非常着迷，收养了她，抚养她长大。然后等她到了妙龄，他便强占了她。而紫发现这是一段极其痛苦的经历。她当时多大年纪？到了妙龄？我想是15岁吧。好吧。是的。
For this rather dubious reason, Genji is very taken with her, adopts her, raises her. And then when she comes of age, he forces himself on her. And Murasaki finds this a deeply traumatic experience. How old is she at this point? Coming of age? 15, I suppose. Okay. Yeah.
我们被告知，她从未料到他会有这种意图，她只能满心苦涩地纳闷：为什么自己在天真无邪的时候，竟然会去信任一个有着如此可怕想法的人；而且她（你知道的）深受打击。她再次感到被冒犯，走开，然后又回来了。她依然在啜泣。是的。而他的反应是：天哪，你这是在大惊小怪什么啊。哦，源氏让日本失望了。因为将这视为令人发指的行为，显然并不属于时代错位。
And we're told she had never suspected him of such intentions and she could only wonder bitterly why in her innocence, she had ever trusted anyone with such horrid ideas and she's, you know, she's devastated. Again, she's a bit offended, goes away, comes back. She's still sobbing. Yeah. And his response is, well, what a fuss you're making. Oh, Genji has let Japan down. Because it's clearly not anachronistic to see this as appalling behavior.
没错。小说字里行间都写明了紫受到了创伤，而源氏似乎对此不以为然。但紫依然对忠于他，我想部分原因是因为她依赖他。她知道如果没有他，自己将陷入贫困。我们在全书中都被告知，一个失去父母、没有前途的年轻女孩如果活得比父母久，面临的将是——引述原话——“沦为尼姑或投海自尽”。好吧。所以这两个选项都不是紫想要接受的。因此她留在了源氏身边，源氏也一直对她一往情深。她原谅了他，对他死心塌地，尽管他宅邸里有那么多不同的女人，
Right. It's written into the fabric of the novel that that Murasaki is traumatized that Genji doesn't seem to understand why. But Murasaki remains devoted to him, I suppose, in part because she is dependent on him. She knows that she would be suffering penury without him. We're told throughout the novel that a young girl without prospects who outlives her parents faces to quote becoming a nun or drowning herself in the sea. Okay. So neither option is one that Murasaki wants to embrace. So she sticks with Genji and Genji remains devoted to her. She forgives him, becomes devoted to him, and although there are all these various women
但所有人都知道，紫尽管社会地位低下，却是真正的正妻。她被称为“统治着源氏府邸的夫人”。他们之间的爱情，我认为非常感人地在岁月中不断加深，因为你追踪了他们极长的一段时间，从源氏的角度来看是从生到死。他们之间的关系被描绘得具有不可思议的微妙、丰富和同情心。所以在死前不久，源氏凝视着紫：他纳闷，年复一年，日复一日，她怎么总是能带有一种奇妙的、新鲜的特质呢？而当她去世时，这彻底击垮了他，不久之后他自己也离世了。这就是他勾引她、行为恶劣的那种复杂性。
in his house, everyone knows that Murasaki, despite her low social status, is the real chief wife. She's referred to as the lady who reigns over Genji's household. Their love, very movingly, I think, deepens over the course of the years, because it's so long that you are tracking them going from, in Genji's case, from birth to death. And their relationship is drawn with incredible subtlety and richness and compassion. So shortly before his death, Genji gazes at Murasaki, how he wondered, was it possible that year to year and day
然而与此同时，你又能感受到在他们生命尽头时那场不可思议的伟大爱情。我认为它具备了一部小说所能要求的一切。而且这一切发生在11th世纪。这太惊人了。
to day she always had about her something marvelous, something new? And when she dies, it breaks him and he dies himself soon after. And it's the complexity of the way in which he seduces her, he behaves appallingly. And yet simultaneously you have this sense of an incredible love affair by the end of their life. It does everything that you'd want from a novel, I think. And this is happening in the 11th century. It's amazing.
但与此同时，他还在和别的女人鬼混，对吧？对的。是的。他在和一大堆——你知道的，你刚才说的12岁女孩、朋友的朋友、朋友的女儿、女儿的朋友——鬼混。没错。而且这在当时是完全可以接受的。在这一时期的日本历史中，一个大贵族拥有
But also he's carrying on with other women at the same time there, right? Right. Yeah. He's carrying on with loads of, you know, you said 12 year olds, the friends of friends, the daughters of friends, the friends of daughters. Right. And this is something that is entirely acceptable. It's entirely acceptable for a great nobleman in this period in Japanese history to have, you know,
一个正妻、侧室、被勾引的女性，这完全是合情合理的，所有这些关系同样都被描绘得极具微妙性和复杂性。而且通常非常有趣。所以这有点像，你知道的，达西先生虽然和伊丽莎白·班内特安定下来了，但他也把艾玛留在了身边。他有，我不知道，范妮·普莱斯。他有贝茨小姐。他周围聚集了一整圈女性。所以你拥有这一切。
a main wife, subordinate wives, people who seduced and all these relationships likewise are drawn with great kind of subtlety and complexity. And it's often very funny. So it's a bit like, you know, Mr. Darcy has settled down with Elizabeth Bennett, but he's also got Emma there. He's got, I don't know, Fanny Price. He's got Miss Bates. He's got a whole range of women gathered around him. So you have all that.
但除此之外，另一件事是，由于时间的流逝，由于你看到源氏本人以及他所爱的所有女性都在变老，小说对时间的流逝以及喜怒哀乐等强烈体验被反复描绘得如樱花般短暂——这在日本是伟大的隐喻——表现得极为感人。我的意思是，他们太爱这个了。日本小说中的樱花隐喻，汤姆。你真是让我大开眼界。嗯，我认为这部小说为之开辟了道路。没错。而且这些角色一次又一次地在“追寻逝去的时光”——这当然是另一部伟大的现代欧洲小说的书名，马塞尔·普鲁斯特的《追寻逝去的时光》（À la recherche du temps perdu），这被普遍认为
But also the other thing is that because you have this passage of time, because you see Genji himself and all the various women that he loves aging, The novel is very moving about the passage of time and about how the kind of intense experiences of joy and sorrow and love are repeatedly portrayed as being kind of as ephemeral as cherry blossom, which is the great metaphor in Japan. I mean, they love that. A cherry blossom metaphor in a Japanese novel, Tom. You astound me. Well, I think that this novel is blazing the path for that. Right. And again and again, these characters are kind of in search of lost time, which of course is the title of another great modern European novel, Alarasheshu Tompedu in search of lost time by Marcel Proust, which
我想，是20th世纪两三部最伟大的小说之一。但它是在一千年后出版的。是的。我在阅读时发现，自己不断地被它提醒。我想，我只是在胡思乱想吗？当我回到家后，我又去谷歌了一下，发现这个对比绝对不是我原创的。我的意思是，有大量关于这方面的文章。我实际上发现这是波士顿日本研究教授 J·凯斯·文森特（J. Keith Vincent）的评论。
is widely held to be, I guess, you know, one of the two or three greatest novels of the 20th century. But is published a thousand years later. Yeah. And I thought, kind of reading it, I was endlessly being reminded of it. And I thought, am I just imagining it? And again, I went and kind of Googled it when I got back home and discovered that the comparison is absolutely not original to me. I mean, there is loads and loads of kind of writing on this. And I found actually that this is a comment by J. Keith Vincent, who is Professor of Japanese Studies at Boston.
显然大约三个月前，他刚刚就这个话题做过一场演讲。这是他在宣传讲座时给出的赞誉，谈到了《源氏物语》与普鲁斯特小说的相似之处。这两部小说都讲述了欲望带来的痛苦，讲述了人类倾向于寻找替代品而不是放弃最初的爱情，以及一切如何枯萎、一切如何消逝，包括悲伤本身。感人，非常感人。所以这是一个相当了不起的对比，不是吗？当你想到它们相隔一千年，而且显然这并不是人们
And he gave a lecture on this very topic about three months ago, apparently. And this is the praise he gave in his advert for it, talking about the Taylor Genji and Proust novel. That both novels tell of the suffering caused by desire of the way human beings seek replacements rather than renouncing their earliest loves and how everything withers, everything perishes, including grief itself. Moving, very moving. So that's a pretty extraordinary comparison to make, isn't it? When you think they're a thousand years apart and obviously it's not the only one that people
唯一的对比。所以有些人把它和《安娜·卡列尼娜》或《战争与和平》之类的作品作对比。是的。所以托尔斯泰是另一个巨大的对比。是的。那么它是否超越了时代？显然没有，因为它是时代的产物。它写于11th世纪的日本。是的。
make. So some people have compared it to Anna Karenina or War and Peace or something. Yeah. So Tolstoy is the other great comparison. Yeah. Is it therefore, well, is it out of time? And obviously it isn't because it's the product of it. It's written in 11th century Japan. Yeah.
没错，正是如此。那么我们该如何解释这一点呢？我们如何解释这样一部对我们来说如此现代的作品，竟然出自一个社会——嗯，这是一个中世纪社会。这是一个拥有武士，你知道的，我想象中有城堡或宫殿之类东西的社会，一个与你认为它所产出的文化完全格格不入的世界？我认为，这种文学形式如何在欧洲在19th和20th世纪达到其经典
Right. Exactly. So how do we explain that? How do we explain that something that seems to us so modern is coming out of a society that well, it's a medieval society. It's a society of people with swords and, you know, I guess castles or whatever or palaces and a world that just seems completely out of sync with the culture that you think it's producing. I think that question of how is it that a literary form that kind of achieves its canonical
地位的同时，日本却能在11th世纪初产出一部同等水平的小说，这个问题正是它之所以应该出现在历史播客中的原因，因为这是一个引人入胜的问题。而且我也认为，试图回答这个问题将为我们打开一扇窗户，让我们得以一窥日本在其第一个黄金时代的政治、文化和社会。是的，这就是我们将在下半部分要做的事情，尝试回答那些问题。日本在其第一个黄金时代。所以这就是我们在下半部分要做的，尝试回答那些问题。我们将通过回答也许是所有问题中最显而易见的一个来开始，细心的
status in Europe in the 19th and 20th century, how is Japan producing an equivalent novel in the early 11th century? And that's why I think it belongs on a history podcast because that's a fascinating question. And I think also that trying to answer that question will open a window onto the politics, onto the culture, onto the society of Japan during its first golden age. Yeah. So that's what we'll be doing in the second half, kind of trying to answer those questions. society of Japan during its first golden age. So that's what we were doing in the second half, kind of trying to answer those questions. And we will begin it by answering perhaps the most obvious question of all, which attentive
听众可能已经意识到，这个问题一直“悬而未决”。非常明显的问题。究竟是谁写了《源氏物语》？天哪。好吧，要想知道这个谜团的答案，请在休息后回来。没有人喜欢她。他们都说她自命不凡、笨拙、难以接近、带刺、过于迷恋她的故事、傲慢、爱掉书袋、目空一切、脾气暴躁且尖酸刻薄。
listeners will have realized, you know, has been left hanging. Very obvious question. Who actually wrote the tale of Genji? Golly. Well, for the answer to that mystery, come back after the break. No one liked her. They all said she was pretentious, awkward, difficult to approach, prickly, too fond of her tales, haughty, prone to versifying, disdainful, cantankerous and scornful.
但当你真正见到她时，她却出奇地温顺，完全是另一个人。这就是《源氏物语》作者的自我写照，她曾是皇宫里的一位女官，从这段阅读中你大概已经猜到，她竟然是一名女性。所以源氏并不是像你原以为的那样是一个男性的幻想化身——你可能会觉得这是一种男性的，你知道的，他很有魅力，浑身香水味，跟所有的女士睡觉——是的，某种愿望实现。是的，愿望实现。但不是，这是女性的作品，而且她的名字，汤姆，是紫式部。我读到她出生于970年代初，卒于1020年。我说她叫紫式部。
But when you meet her, she is strangely meek, a completely different person altogether. So that is a self-portrait written by the author of The Tale of Genji, who was a courtier at the Imperial Palace and you will have guessed from that reading that she was of all things a woman. So Genji is not a male fantasy figure as you might have thought he was you might have thought this was a kind of male you know his charming his perfumed he sleeps with all the ladies yeah kind of wish fulfillment yeah wish fulfillment but no this is the work of a woman and her name, Tom is Mirosaki Shikibu. And I read she was born in the early nine seventies and died in 10 20. I say she was called Mirosaki Shikibu.
嗯，她被称为紫式部，但这真的是她的名字吗？不，我们不知道她的真实名字。原因在于，在日本宫廷的皇室社会中，只有仆人才倾向于用他们的真名来称呼。男性和女性都是如此。所以男性通常以他们的头衔相称。因此，以源氏为例，在小说的进程中，他先后被称为，
Well, she was known as Mirosaki Shikibu, but was that actually her name? No, we don't know her real name. And the reason for that is that in the Imperial Society of the Japanese court, um, only servants tended to be called by their real names. And this is true of men as well as women. So men are called by their titles. So Genji, to take the obvious example, over the course of the novel, he is called successfully,
我只读……你知道，读其中的一部分——中将、右大将、权中纳言、大人、内大臣等等，等等，等等。当然，他最终以荣誉退休天皇的身份收场。而且在整部小说中，人们往往用他们的头衔来指代，这可能会让人非常困惑，因为你知道，某人在章节中途升官了。哦，他们的头衔变了。突然之间很难弄清楚他是谁。其实我们录音时也会这么做，对吧？因为我们叫他西奥（Theo）……
I'll read just, you know, read some of them, the captain, the commander of the right, acting grand counselor, his grace, the palace minister, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. And of course he ends up as the honorary retired Emperor. And throughout the novel people tend to be referred to by their titles and this can be quite confusing because you know someone gets promoted midway through a chapter. Oh and their title changes. Suddenly quite difficult to work out who he is. So actually we already do this don't we because I mean we call him Theo when we're recording
我只读，你知道的，读其中一些，右厢指挥使、代理宰相、他的阁下、宫廷大臣等等，等等，等等。当然，他最后成了退休的太上皇。整部小说中，人们往往用他们的头衔来称呼，这可能会相当混乱，因为你知道有人在一个章节的中途得到了晋升。哦，他们的头衔变了。突然之间很难搞清楚他是谁。所以实际上我们已经在这样做了，不是吗？因为我的意思是我们在录音时叫他西奥
just to please the audience but in reality we mean, we call him Theo when we're recording just to please the audience. But in reality, we call, we just call him you and I when we're talking about him. We just call him the podcast producer. Yeah. That's his name. Yeah. I mean, to me, that's who he is. I've just saved him on my phone and my WhatsApp. He just comes up as part of the podcast producer. Yeah. And of course we do also have Tabby, but of course Tabby is a woman. Do you know how I refer to Tabby? So Tabby, when she comes up on my phone, I just put rest is history foreign office. And we will explain why. Because there are kind of slightly different rules governing how women in the Japanese court are named. So they have kind of a range of nicknames. They don't tend to have titles. So Genji's mother, for instance, who we
只是为了取悦听众，但实际上我的意思是，我们在录音时叫他西奥只是为了取悦听众。但实际上，我们在谈论他时，只会叫他，只会叫他“你”和“我”。我们只会叫他播客制作人。对。这就是他的名字。对。我的意思是，对我来说，他就是这样的人。我把他的电话和WhatsApp存下来了。他显示出来的名字就是“播客制作人”。对。当然，我们还有塔比，但塔比是个女性。你知道我是怎么备注塔比的吗？所以塔比，当她的电话打进来时，我只写了“历史其余部分外交部”。我们会解释原因。因为日本宫廷中女性的命名规则略有不同。所以她们有一系列昵称。她们往往没有头衔。比如源氏的母亲，我们在
introduced to him in that opening paragraph, she is initially called the Kiritsubu Intimate because she's sleeping with the emperor, hence intimate, and she lives in a section of the palace called the Kiritsubu. And anyone who's familiar with the palace will know that this is not a bad place to be, but it's not the best bit. So it immediately establishes her kind of position in the pecking order. And then when she delivers Genji her name changes And she gets called the Kiritsubu Haven. Okay a Haven is a kind of unofficial
开篇段落中向大家介绍过她，她最初被称为“桐壶更衣”，因为她伺候皇帝，所以被称为“更衣”，她住在宫中被称为“桐壶”的区域。任何熟悉宫廷的人都知道，这地方不算差，但也不是最好的位置。所以这立即确立了她在权力阶层中的地位。然后，当她生下源氏时，她的名字变了，她被称为“桐壶殿”。好吧，“殿”是一种非官方的
title for a woman who has a born a child to either an emperor or an heir apparent and Literally, it means I kind of read up on this It literally means a place in which the August seed has found rest. Okay. So the feminist critics must enjoy that. Yeah, exactly. So, so if you are a haven, that's what's happened to you. Right.
头衔，授予那些为皇帝或皇位继承人生下孩子的女性。字面意思，我查过这个词，字面意思就是“皇嗣之种找到安息之所的地方”。好吧。那女权主义评论家一定会喜欢这个。对，没错。所以，如果你是一个“殿”，这就是发生在你身上的事。对吧。
But obviously not everyone gets pregnant by an Empress. No, you're not. Not everyone's a haven. So what of women who don't have that status, you might be given a nickname that comes from kind of almost anything. So Murasaki Shikibu, Murasaki comes from the name of her heroine in the novel. Okay.
但显然不是每个人都能怀上皇帝的孩子。不，不是这样的。不是每个人都能成为“殿”。那么，没有这种身份的女性呢？你可能会得到一个几乎可以源自任何事物的昵称。比如紫式部，“紫”这个名字来自于小说中她女主角的名字。好吧。
She's identified with, with Genji's great love. So that's where it comes from. And Shikibu, it's the place where her father worked. So he was a court official working in the ministry of ceremonials. So he's responsible for all the kind of parades and things like that. And so hence, that's why we call Tabby Rest is History Foreign Office because her father was a diplomat. So you're defined, if you're a woman, you're defined by your father's rank, basically. Yes. And this is the case with this Murasaki Shikibu. Yes. And she is very, very aware of the opportunities that are open to men that are shut to her as a woman. And
她与源氏挚爱的人联系在了一起。所以名字就来源于此。“式部”是她父亲工作的地方。他是一位在式部省工作的宫廷官员。他负责所有的游行和类似的事情。因此，这就是为什么我们把塔比称为“历史其余部分外交部”，因为她的父亲是一位外交官。所以，如果你是一个女性，你基本上是由你父亲的阶层来定义的。是的。紫式部也是如此。是的。而且她非常非常清楚，男人们可以获得的机会作为女性的她是无法得到的，并且
she, she clearly has been since she was a child, because in her diary, which you quoted from her self description. Yeah, that's an amazing piece of work, the diary. And she wrote that for a couple of years in the first decades of the 11th century. So while she's in the midst of writing the tale of Genji, and she recorded this incredibly telling episode from her youth. And it was when her brother was being taught by her father the lessons that would be appropriate to him as a boy who's destined for imperial service. And Murasaki wrote,
很明显，她从小就意识到了这一点，因为在她引用自己自我描述的日记中……对，日记是一部了不起的作品。那是她在11世纪的前几十年里写了几年日记。正是在她创作《源氏物语》期间，她记录了这段来自她童年的极具启示意义的插曲。当时她的哥哥正在接受她父亲的教导，学习作为一名注定要为皇家服务的男孩所应掌握的功课。紫式部写道：
I was in the habit of listening with him. And I became unusually proficient at understanding those lessons with which he was struggling. My father, a most learned man, was always regretting this fact. Just my luck, he would say, what a pity she was not born a man. Again, worth re-emphasizing, this is being written in the age of the Anglo-Saxons. I mean, imagine if we had a diary like this. I know. Written by an Anglo-Saxon woman. I mean, it's unthinkable, but it existed.
我习惯和他一起听讲。对于他正在苦苦挣扎的那些功课，我表现出了异乎寻常的理解能力。我父亲是一个极其博学的人，总是为此感到遗憾。他总是说：“我真倒霉，可惜她不是个男儿身。”再次值得强调的是，这是在盎格鲁-撒克逊时代写成的。我的意思是，想象一下如果我们有这样一本日记。我懂的。由一位盎格鲁-撒克逊女性所写。我的意思是，这简直不可想象，但它确实存在。
People may remember we have the life of Edward the Confessor that was clearly inspired by Edith, his wife, but she doesn't write it herself, even though she's very educated. No, exactly. Whereas Murasaki, you know, there's no issue with that. And it is amazing. I think that, I mean, being anachronistic to call it feminist, but clearly the sense of resentment that men are monopolizing education. I mean, you get that through in China or in the Caliphate or in Latin Christendom, but you don't have anyone, I think, as far as I know, expressing it quite so personally
人们可能还记得，我们有《忏悔者爱德华生平》，这显然是受他的妻子伊迪丝启发而写的，但她并不是自己写的，尽管她很有教养。不，确实如此。而紫式部，你知道的，这方面没有任何问题。这太了不起了。我认为，虽然称其为女权主义有点不合时代，但显然那种认为男性垄断教育的怨恨情绪——我的意思是，你在中国、哈里发国或拉丁基督教世界都能感受到这一点，但据我所知，没有人像紫式部那样表达得如此个人化
as Murasaki does there. So obviously part of this must depend upon her own personal qualities. So you've mentioned them in your notes, the fact that she's very learned. I mean, she's been listening to all the lessons. She's a very good observer. She's bright. She's determined. Yeah. You know, all of those things. Plus she's in the Imperial court. So she's able to reserve all this. Yeah. But what does it tell us about Japanese society? Because presumably there must be a deeper explanation for why a woman is able to produce this at this point in time time at this place.
正如紫式部在那儿所做的那样。所以很显然，这其中一部分必然取决于她个人的素质。你在笔记中也提到了这一点，她非常博学。我的意思是，她一直在听所有的功课。她观察力极强。她很聪慧。她意志坚定。对。你知道，所有这些。再加上她身处宫廷。所以她能够把这些都记在心里。对。但这告诉了我们关于日本社会的什么信息呢？因为据推测，为什么一个女性能够在此时此地的这个地方创作出这样的作品，背后一定有更深层的原因。
Yeah, so I think there are kind of deep structural reasons for it and they're well worth exploring not just for their own sake, but because they tell us a lot about how Japan kind of emerges as a distinctive civilization. So just sticking to Murasaki for a moment, one of the nicknames that she's given at court, and it really upsets her because it's meant kind of mockingly, almost cruelly, is Lady Chronicle. And the Chronicles in Japan are the two oldest surviving texts that we have, and they were written in the early 8th century AD, and the first of these was written in Japanese and the second was written in Chinese and between them they give a history of Japan that actually begins with the creation of the universe.
是的，所以我认为这其中有深刻的结构性原因，非常值得去探讨，不仅为了它们本身，还因为它们向我们展示了日本是如何作为一个独特的文明崛起的。就拿紫式部来说，宫廷里给她起过一个绰号，这让她非常心烦，因为这个绰号带有嘲讽意味，甚至有点残忍，叫“女纪传”。而日本的“纪传”是我们现存最古老的两部文本，它们写于公元8世纪初，其中第一部是用日语写的，第二部是用汉语写的，这两部书合起来提供了一部日本的历史，这部历史实际上从宇宙的创世开始。
So a lot of that is about kind of the doings of the gods in the early years of the creation and it goes all the way up to the end of the 7th century and they are very clearly written to explain the origins of the imperial line, the line of the emperors and to justify its rule as something that is divinely sanctioned. So what you get from the chronicles is the fact that every emperor is descended from Amaterasu, who is the goddess of the sun. And this is something that is still part of Japanese imperial culture to this day. Of course. I mean, so Charles III doesn't boast about being descended from Woden. No.
因此，其中很大一部分内容都是关于创世初期诸神的作为，一直讲到7世纪末。它们显然是为了解释皇统（即天皇的世系）的起源，并证明其统治是受神圣庇护的。所以从这些编年史中，你可以了解到，每一位天皇都是太阳女神天照大神的后裔。直到今天，这依然是日本皇室文化的一部分。当然。我的意思是，所以查理三世不会吹嘘自己是奥丁的后代。不。
But the current emperor, absolutely. I mean, he's descended from the sun. This is part of imperial ideology. And what we're told in the Chronicles is that the first emperor, a guy called Jimmu, which I think is a great name, is the great grandson of the sun. And he is sent down from heaven and he conquers all the various peoples of Japan, including men whose arms and legs are so long that people call them the earth spiders. And he reigns over Japan and he then dies at the age of 170 and he is followed by a succession of 15 emperors all of whom are very anonymous. They don't really seem to do anything except to have kind of madly, improbably long lives
但当今的天皇，绝对是的。我的意思是，他是太阳的后代。这是皇室意识形态的一部分。编年史告诉我们，第一位天皇，一个叫神武的家伙——我觉得这是个很棒的名字——是太阳的曾孙。他从天而降，征服了日本的各个部族，包括那些手脚长到人们称他们为“土蜘蛛”的人。他统治日本，然后在170岁时去世，接着是15位天皇的继位，他们都非常默默无闻。他们似乎什么也没做，只是拥有
kind of like the patriarchs in the Bible. They're living for kind of 400 300 years all that kind of thing. People do live for a long time in Japan there, don't they? Yeah, but not that long. Okay, not that long. Okay. Not that long. And when you add all these very long lived emperors to the list of more recent emperors in the Chronicles, so those who did exist, who are historical, Japanese history is made to stretch back thousands of years.
疯狂且不可思议的长寿，就像圣经中的先知一样。他们活了400岁、300岁之类的一直如此。日本人确实很长寿，对吧？是的，但没那么长。好吧，没那么长。好吧，没那么长。当你把所有这些极其长寿的天皇加到编年史中更近的天皇名单中时，也就是那些确实存在过、有历史记载的天皇，日本历史就被拉长到了几千年前。
And the reason that this matters is precisely because it doesn't stretch back thousands of years. Interesting. It's actually very, very parvenu. It's actually appeared very recently on the scene. They're protesting too much. They are protesting too much because the Imperial family until pretty recently, you know, a few hundred years before had only been one of a number of kind of great competing families
而这之所以重要，恰恰是因为它并没有延续几千年前。有趣的是。它其实非常暴发户。它实际上是最近才出现在历史舞台上的。他们这是在过度辩解。他们的确在过度辩解，因为直到不久前（几百年前），皇室还只是日本中部、
in central Japan and specifically the Yamato basin. It's the kind of southern central region of Honshu, which is the largest island. So the island that Tokyo is on. Yeah, the middle bit. And even by the time of Murasaki, not all of Honshu had been conquered. So the northern reaches were still kind of, were unstable and Hokkaido, which is the northernmost island, kind of, you know, the barbarians were still kind of roaming there.
特别是大和盆地众多相互竞争的伟大家族之一。那是本州岛（最大岛屿）的中南部地区。也就是东京所在的那个岛屿。是的，中间那个部分。甚至到了紫式部生活的时代，本州岛也并非全部被征服。因此北部地区仍然处于动荡之中，而北海道作为最北端的岛屿，野蛮人依然在那里游荡。
Yeah. So this is why it's incredibly important for the Imperial dynasty and for the entire Japanese system that depends on it to big it up as divine, as ancient, as universal. And so in the seventh century, you get this kind of ringing decree, there are not two suns in the sky nor two lords on the earth. And this is aimed at the other Japanese families. There is only the one imperial family. And in the middle of the seventh century, the Yamato monarch starts to call himself
是的。这就是为什么对于皇室以及依赖它的整个日本体制来说，将其吹捧为神圣的、古老的、普遍的，是极其重要的事情。因此，在7世纪，你听到了这样震撼的诏令：天无二日，土无二王。这针对的是其他日本家族。只有一个皇室。在7世纪中叶，大和君主开始自称为
tenno, which means heavenly sovereign. And by the early eighth century, what had previously been Yamato, so the region where this Imperial family has come from, is starting to be called the root of the sun, which in Japanese is Nihon, from which the English word Japan ultimately derives. So I guess if you know nothing about Japanese history, like me, all of this sounds pretty familiar. It's not unheard of at all in Eurasian history for monarchies to become more centralized, more powerful.
“天皇”，意思是天之君主。到了8世纪初，以前被称为“大和”的地方——也就是这个皇室发源的地区——开始被称为“日之本”，日文发源于此，英文单词“Japan”最终也由此演变而来。所以我想，如果你像我一样对日本历史一无所知，所有这一切听起来都相当熟悉。君主制变得更加集权、更加强大，这在欧亚大陆历史上并不是闻所未闻的。
When they do so, they develop a kind of cult and they develop a myth, a backstory. So Japan in that sense is maybe not massively unusual. And of course, Japan is being influenced isn't it by a neighbor because Japan is not in a bubble and Japan is not the only country in East Asia that has an Emperor and that sees itself as the center of the universe and of course this brings us to its colossal mainland neighbor which is China. Right and so you said you know this is quite a familiar story. I mean, there are perhaps elements here of Charlemagne crowning himself in Rome and aping the titles of the emperor in Constantinople.
当它们这样做时，它们会发展出一种崇拜，发展出一个神话、一个背景故事。从这个意义上说，日本或许并没有什么太不寻常的地方。当然，日本也受到了邻国的影响，不是吗？因为日本并非生活在气泡中，而且日本也不是东亚唯一一个拥有天皇、并将自己视为宇宙中心的国家。当然，这也把我们带到了它那庞大的大陆邻国——中国。对，所以你刚才说，这其实是一个相当熟悉的故事。我的意思是，这其中或许包含了一些查理三世在罗马加冕并模仿君士坦丁堡皇帝头衔的元素。
Okay. But China is a much more domineering superpower than the Byzantine Empire is in the age of Charlemagne. I mean, it is the preponderant cultural influence in the region of Asia that Japan is attached to. So that very decree that is issued saying that the Japanese emperor is the only son in the sky, I mean that is lifted absolutely from the Chinese. And the word tenno, the title that is often translated as emperor, this also derives from China. It's a Chinese word and it means the pole star star which the Chinese saw as being the throne of heaven. And so this being so, the Chinese, a bit like the
好吧。但与查理三世时期的拜占庭帝国相比，中国是一个更具统治力的超级大国。我的意思是，它是日本所依附的亚洲地区最具支配地位的文化影响。因此，那份宣称日本天皇是天空中唯一太阳的诏令——我的意思是，这绝对是从中国抄袭过来的。而“天皇”这个经常被翻译为皇帝的头衔，也源自中国。这是一个中国词汇，意思是北极星，中国古人将其视为天庭的宝座。既然如此，中国人就像
Byzantines with Charlemagne, and they treat the pretensions of the Japanese with utter contempt. Yeah. There's a lovely story about a letter, isn't there? I love this story. Yeah. So the Yamato court sends a letter to China in the early seventh century and they say the child of heaven of the land where the sun rises. So again, that's this idea of Nihon, the root of the sun, sends a letter to the child of heaven of the land where the sun sets. So that's China. And this is supposedly brought to the attention of the Chinese emperor who retorts, this letter from the barbarians contains improprieties. Do not call it to my attention again. So that's the Japanese kind of dealt with. Yeah. But these
拜占庭人对待查理三世一样，对日本人的狂妄自大持彻底蔑视的态度。是的。有一个关于一封信的有趣故事，对吧？我很喜欢这个故事。是的。因此，大和朝廷在7世纪初给中国写了一封信，他们说：“日出处天子，致书日落处天子无恙。”所以这再次体现了“日之本”的想法，即太阳升起的地方，给太阳落下地方的天子写信，也就是中国。这封信据说呈给中国皇帝过目，中国皇帝反驳说：“此蛮夷书无礼节，勿复以闻。”所以日本人就这样被打发了。是的。但这些
rebuffs do not stop the Japanese monarchy from kind of aping the Chinese model. And in fact, from kind of consciously trying to model almost everything in Japan on the example of China. So in the early seventh century, this, this kind of introduction of the Japanese monarchy on a Chinese model is termed by historians, the great reform. And as part of it, scholars and officials are sponsored to go to China to study it and then to come back and report. And they bring back Confucian ideals, so this idea of a great civil service serving the emperor, a centralized monarchy, a meritocratic civil service, all the things that we're familiar with from Chinese history, but also with the literary culture. So very rapidly, Chinese becomes, I suppose, what Latin is in medieval European courts. It's the language that anyone with any pretension to education, anyone with any hope of rising
回绝并没有阻止日本君主模仿中国的模式。事实上，他们是有意识地试图将日本几乎所有的东西都按照中国的范例进行塑造。因此在7世纪初，这种以中国模式引入日本君主制的做法被历史学家称为“大化改新”。作为其中的一部分，学者和官员被资助前往中国学习，然后回来汇报。他们带回了儒家思想，也就是庞大的文官服务皇帝的思想、集权君主制、精英官僚体制——所有这些我们从中国历史中熟悉的元素，以及文学文化。因此很快，汉字就变成了我所认为的欧洲中世纪宫廷中的拉丁语。任何有点文化追求的人、任何希望在
in the service of the emperor has to be able to read and speak. And when written Japanese is developed, it uses Chinese writing. So those chronicles which are describing and praising the antiquity of the Japanese monarchy, first one's written in Japanese, as we said, but the second one is in Chinese. I mean, it's amazing that, you know, a patriotic history is being written in a foreign language. But I suppose you would write a patriotic history in Europe in Latin, conceivably in the medieval period. And that's the comparison, right?
天皇手下高升的人，都必须能够阅读和说这种语言。当书面日语发展起来时，它使用的是汉字。因此，那些描述和赞美日本君主制古老历史的编年史，正如我们所说，第一部是用日语写的，但第二部是用汉语写的。我的意思是，一部爱国史竟然是用外语写成的，这真是令人惊叹。不过我想，在欧洲中世纪时期，你也可以用拉丁语写一部爱国史。这就是类比，对吧？
You have the hegemon and its culture. Well, it's hegemonic, hence the name. Yeah. And in the early eighth century, when the first permanent capital in Japan is founded, so up until that moment, the convention had been that every time an emperor died, the court would move to another location. But this is clearly not the Chinese way. The Chinese have a massive great capital, Chang'an.
你拥有霸权及其文化。好吧，它是霸权主义的，所以才叫这个名字。是的。到了8世纪初，当日本第一个永久首都建立时——直到那个时候，惯例一直是每当天皇驾崩，朝廷就要迁往另一个地方。但这显然不是中国的方式。中国有一个宏伟的大首都，长安。
And so the Japanese monarchy founds its own capital, which comes to be called Nara. So again, in the region of Yamato where the family had emerged. And it's directly, slavishly modeled on the region of Yamato where the family had emerged and it's directly slavishly modeled on the example of Chang'an. It has this kind of grid system, large numbers of immigrants are invited over from China and from Korea. So these are not just scholars, they're also artists, architects, dancers, musicians, writers, complete sinomania. And in fact, people who want to study early Chinese dance or music, because so much of this was wiped out by the Mongols in China itself, if they wanted to learn about it, they look at Japan, where it was kind of better preserved.
于是，日本君主制建立了属于自己的首都，后来被称为“平城京”（Nara）。同样是在大和地区，这个家族就是从这里崛起的。它直接、奴性地模仿了长安的样式。它采用了这种网格系统，大量的移民被邀请从中国和朝鲜来到这里。所以这些人不仅是学者，还有艺术家、建筑师、舞者、音乐家、作家，完全是一种“中国狂热”。事实上，那些想要研究中国古代舞蹈或音乐的人——因为这些在中国本土大部分被蒙古人消灭了——如果他们想了解这些，就会看看日本，因为那里保存得相对较好。
And just to quote Ivan Morris, he's written a brilliant book on the tale of Genji, the world of the Shining Prince. And he writes, really in the history of the world has a country entirely free from external pressure as Japan was during this time. So avidly acquired the fruits of an alien culture. And I guess the only other real example would be the Meiji restoration, which is when Japan had shut itself off from the world for what 250 years. Yes.
正如伊万·莫里斯（Ivan Morris）所说，他写了一本关于《源氏物语》的精彩著作——《辉煌的王子之世界》，他写道：“在世界历史上，几乎没有哪个像日本这样在当时完全不受外部压力影响的国家，能如此狂热地汲取异域文化的成果。”我想唯一的另一个真正的例子就是明治维新，当时日本把自己与世界隔绝了，大概250年吧？是的。
And then in the 19th century, it opens itself up to the world of the West. But Japan doesn't become a new China does it? Because it's got its own resilient national culture and sense of national distinctiveness and there's a sort of, you know, there's a tension there, right? That the Japanese are both copying China, but also they, they are very conscious of their own Japaneseness. Yeah. And also there's kind of massive pressures on society because the nobility haven't gone
然后在19世纪，它向西方世界开放了自己。但日本并没有变成一个新的中国，对吧？因为它有自己坚韧的民族文化和民族独特性意识，而且这里存在着某种，你知道的，某种张力，对吧？日本人既在模仿中国，但他们同时也非常清醒地意识到自己的“日本性”。是的。而且社会上也存在着巨大的压力，因为贵族阶层并没有
away and the Confucian supposedly meritocratic bureaucracy gets set up. But the nobles aren't interested in this at all. You know, they're not going to subordinate themselves to a load of civil servants who've passed an exam. And so throughout the eighth century, while the monarchy is resident in Nara, they are furiously competing with one another not to overthrow the monarchy, but to dominate it. And the way they do this is they're all competing to try and marry off their daughters to the emperor. And if the emperor then has a son, their son will become emperor. And it breeds kind of escalating factionalism on the streets.
消失，而所谓的儒家精英官僚机构也建立了起来。但贵族们对这一套根本不感兴趣。你知道的，他们才不会让自己服从于一群通过考试的公务员。因此在整个8世纪，当君主制居住在平城京时，他们之间展开了激烈的竞争，不是为了推翻君主制，而是为了支配它。而他们做到这一点的方式，就是争先恐后地把自己的女儿嫁给天皇。如果天皇生了个儿子，他们的儿子就会成为天皇。这在街头滋生了不断升级的派系斗争。
The emperor finds it very difficult to keep control and he finds his own authority being submerged by the kind of the intensity of noble factionalism. So in the 790s, an emperor called Canmu decides enough is enough, you know, Nara is hopeless, we can't maintain our control here. So we're going and found a new monarchy. It's actually rather like Louis XIV abandoning Paris. And he comes across the site of Versailles when he's out hunting. And Canmu likewise comes across the site where he wants to plant his new capital while he is out hunting. And it's a location that seems to him ideal. So it's about 30-40 miles from Nara and it is defended to the north, to the east, to the west by mountains thick with trees.
天皇发现很难维持控制，他发现自己的权威正被贵族派系斗争的激烈程度所淹没。所以在790年代，一个名叫桓武的天皇决定“够了”，你知道的，平城京没救了，我们无法在这里维持控制。所以我们要离开，建立一个新的君主制。这其实有点像路易十四抛弃巴黎。他在打猎时偶然发现了凡尔赛的遗址。桓武也是在打猎时偶然发现了自己想要建立新都城的地点。这个地方在他看来是理想的。它距离平城京大约30到40英里，北面、东面和西面都有树木葱郁的山脉作为屏障。
It's linked by rivers to the sea, very navigable. The soil is very, very fertile and it's perfect. So Kanmu establishes his new capital there. He calls it Heian, Kyo, the city of peace and tranquility. So Kyo is city and this is the city that in due course will come to be called Kyoto. And Kyoto or Heian, Kyo as it is at this point, it's interesting, isn't it? Because it's very, very explicitly modeled on a Chinese exemplar on Chang'an, the great imperial capital of China, but on a much bigger scale
它通过河流与大海相连，非常利于航行。土壤非常非常肥沃，堪称完美。于是，桓武在那里建立了他的新都城。他将其命名为“平安京”（Heian-kyo），意为和平与安宁之城。所以“京”就是城市的意思。这座城市日后将被人们称为“京都”。而京都，或者说当时的“平安京”，非常有趣，不是吗？因为它非常非常明确地以中国的典范——中国伟大的帝王首都长安为蓝本，但规模要比
than Nara. Yeah. So you have this great palace, which is in the north. You have markets to the south, a bit like Manhattan. You have kind of great avenues and streets crossing each other at right angles. It's supposed to be entirely symmetrical. In fact, it very rapidly doesn't because it kind of drifts to the right and the left kind of gets slightly abandoned.
平城京大得多。是的。所以你拥有这座位于北部的宏伟宫殿。南面有市场，有点像曼哈顿。你拥有相互以直角交叉的大道和街道。它本该是完全对称的。事实上，它很快就变得不再对称了，因为它有点向右偏斜，左边部分有点被荒废了。
And I think that that's the kind of perfect metaphor for what is happening with Japan generally that they continue to model themselves on China, but everything is being kind of transmuted into something kind of subtly different. Right. So Chinese institutions do remain the kind of the great model of government. The prestige of Chinese culture remains paramount. Chinese merchandise continues to flood Japan, but increasingly people in the Japanese court are thinking, well, we've got everything that we need now.
我认为这其实是日本普遍现状的完美隐喻：他们继续以中国为蓝本，但一切都在被转化为某种微妙不同的东西。对。因此中国制度确实仍然是治国的大模型。中国文化的威望仍然至高无上。中国商品继续涌入日本，但日本宫廷里的人们越来越多地在想，好吧，我们现在已经拥有了我们需要的一切。
Again, a bit like Japan in the 20th century, having, you know, gone through a process of westernization, then thinks, fine, we don't need the West anymore. We'll improve it. And exactly a century after the founding of Hayaan Kyo in 894, the Japanese government therefore decides as a matter of policy that it will no longer send embassies to China. Cuts itself off rather as it would go on to do in the 17th century. So that by the time that Murasaki is born, the number of foreigners coming to Japan has kind of slowed to a trickle.
再次有点像20世纪的日本，经历了一系列西化过程后，然后觉得，好吧，我们不再需要西方了。我们会自己完善它。就在平安京建立整整一个世纪后的公元894年，日本政府因此作为一项政策决定，不再向中国派遣遣唐使。切断了联系，就像它在17世纪将要做的那样。因此，当紫式部出生时，来到日本的外国人数量已经减少到涓涓细流。
And it's really telling that in the tale of Genji, actually the only foreigner who speaks in the entire vast sweep of the novel is a Korean physiognomist who reads a child's future in his face and he's introduced to the seven-year-old Genji and says, wow, he's amazing. But for some reason, he's not going to be an emperor. And this is one of the things that prompts the emperor then to do what he does. So that was set up this world of the future Kyoto here in Kyoto. And we've got the relationship between Chinese and Japanese. What does that tell us about Murasaki and the origins of the tale of Genji? So we've compared Chinese to Latin.
非常说明问题的是，在《源氏物语》中，实际上在整部宏大漫长的小说中，唯一开口说话的外国人是一个朝鲜相士，他通过面相解读了一个孩子的未来。他被引见给七岁的源氏，并说：“哇，他太棒了！”但出于某种原因，他不会成为天皇。而这也是促使天皇做出后来的举动的原因之一。所以这就奠定了未来平安京这个世界的基础。我们了解了中国和日本之间的关系。这向我们揭示了关于紫式部和《源氏物语》起源的什么信息？所以我们将中国比作拉丁语。
And of course, the thing with Latin is that for people who are speaking it in medieval Europe, it is a marker of tremendous status. And I guess that must still be the case in Japan, right? Yeah, and specifically of masculine status. So remember that passage where Murasaki describes her brother, who's clearly not as bright as her, struggling with his lessons. What he's struggling with is learning Chinese. Yeah. Murasaki learns Chinese to a great degree of facility. She loves it.
当然，对于中世纪欧洲说拉丁语的人来说，拉丁语是巨大社会地位的标志。我想这在日本也一定如此，对吧？是的，而且具体来说是男性身份的标志。还记得紫式部描述她哥哥的那段吗？他明显不如她聪明，在功课上挣扎。他苦苦挣扎的正是学习汉语。是的。紫式部以极高的熟练程度学会了汉语。她非常喜欢它。
But this is seen in the Japanese court as un-ladylike, almost as freakish. A lady who speaks Chinese is, you know, faintly off-putting to men. And so at court she tries to keep her knowledge of Chinese a secret, which is why she's so upset at being called Lady Chronicle, because clearly her fellow ladies in waiting have discovered it and are kind of mocking her, I suppose, as a kind of nerd. It's that kind of idea, I think. And she's very upset by this, but she loves Chinese so much that she's not going to stop reading it.
但这在日本宫廷中被视为没有女性仪态，几乎是怪异的。一个会说汉语的女性，你知道的，会让男性感到有些敬而远之。因此，在宫廷里，她尽量对自己的汉语知识保密，这也是为什么她听到别人叫她“女纪传”时会如此心烦，因为这显然意味着她的宫女同伴们已经发现了这一点，并且大概像嘲笑书呆子一样在嘲笑她。我想就是那种想法。她对此非常沮丧，但她太喜欢汉语了，以至于不会停止阅读它。
And in her diary, kind of very moving passage, if you have ever been a bookish child, you can kind of absolutely identify with it. She describes how she copes with, you know, a sense of loneliness and unhappiness by raiding this great stash of Chinese texts that she's found a scholar has got. And she says how much pleasure it gives her to read them. But then she describes, it's like, you know, a bookish child being bullied at school. The other women gather behind my back. It's because she goes on like this that she is so miserable. What kind of lady is it who reads Chinese books? And when she goes on to teach the Empress who she's serving Chinese, again, they do it in secret. And in the
在她日记中有一段非常感人的选段——如果你曾经是个书呆子气的小孩，你绝对能对它感同身受。她描述了自己是如何通过翻阅她发现的一位学者珍藏的大量中文典籍来应对孤独和不快乐感的。她描述了阅读这些书带给她的巨大快乐。但随后她描述道，这就好像一个书呆子气的小孩在学校被霸凌一样。其他女人们聚集在我的背后。“她就是因为这样整天才这么痛苦。究竟是什么样的女人才会去读中文书呢？”当她后来教导她所侍奉的中宫皇后学习汉语时，她们同样是秘密进行的。而在《源氏物语》中，
tale of Genji, she portrays the daughter of a great scholar who teaches her lover to do the same. So that's, I mean, a real gender inversion that it's the woman who's teaching the man Chinese. But again, it has to be kept an absolutely kind of deadly secret. And the implication of this that Chinese, its script, its literature is for men, means by implication that to write in Japanese is for women. And by Murasaki's time, the Japanese have developed a kind of phonetic script.
她塑造了一个大学者的女儿，教导她的爱人做同样的事情。所以，我的意思是，这是一个真正的性别反转，是女性在教导男性汉语。但同样，这必须被当作绝对机密保守。而这意味着汉语、它的文字、它的文学是属于男性的，这也就暗含了用日语写作是属于女性的。到了紫式部生活的时代，日本人已经发展出了一种表音文字。
So hiragana, still called back to this day. But in Murasaki's time, it was called anade. So woman's hand, it's a script that is associated with women. Whereas Chinese characters are so associated with men that they are called Otto Komodji, which apparently Japanese kicking in means men's letters. There's men's writing Chinese and there's women's writing, which is this kind of Japanese phonetic script. And presumably as with writing in Latin with the language comes a set of expectations and
也就是平假名，直到今天依然如此称呼。但在紫式部时代，它被称为“假名”（anade）——也就是女人的手笔，这是一种与女性相关的文字。而汉字与男性的联系是如此紧密，以至于被称为“男文字”（Otto Komodji），日语发音显然意味着“男人的文字”。有男人书写的汉语，也有女性书写的文字，也就是这种日语表音文字。而且，正如用拉丁语写作一样，语言本身也伴随着一套期望和
formulas. Yeah, of classics, of models. So the men will write in a particular way, they will follow a Chinese model, but I'm guessing the women, if they're writing in kind of hiragana or on our day, women's hand, they can do what they like, can't they? Because there's no Chinese model. Yeah, exactly. There's no rules.
范式。是的，有经典、有模范。所以男性会以特定的方式写作，他们会遵循中国的模范，但我猜女性如果用平假名或假名（女人的手笔）写作，她们就可以随心所欲，对吧？因为根本没有中国模范可循。是的，完全如此。没有任何规则。
So they can do what they like. Absolutely. And it's clear that Murasaki is writing a kind of diary. There's clearly a sense that the court is the great focus of attention. And it's not much of a leap for Murasaki to say, well, I could make up a great courtier. I could make someone up and situate him in a kind of a world that's faintly removed from reality. And there it is.
所以她们可以随心所欲。绝对的。很明显，紫式部当时在写某种日记。人们显然有一种感觉，宫廷是人们关注的巨大焦点。对于紫式部来说，这并不是跨越式的一步，她可以说：“好吧，我可以虚构一个伟大的朝臣。我可以虚构一个人，把他置于一个与现实有些许距离的世界里。”就是这样。
There you have the great novel that she goes on to write. Right. It's precisely because she's doing it in a woman's hand in a form that has not yet been codified as it were, and for which there are no models that she can effectively invent the Japanese novel. Right. And the evidence of the freedom to experiment that women have in the Heian court is the fact that she is not the only woman there to write a masterpiece because in the next episode, we will be meeting a woman who
你便拥有了她后来创作的伟大小说。没错。正是因为她用女人的手笔、用一种尚未被规范化、也没有任何模范可循的文体进行创作，她才能有效地发明日本小说。没错。平安朝廷中女性拥有实验自由的证据在于，她并不是那里唯一一个写出杰作的女性，因为在下一集中，我们将见到一位女性，她
writes another extraordinary work of literature. She's one of the wittiest, most elegant, most brilliant women who's ever lived. I mean, and again, kind of reading it is just an amazing experience. The sense of an alien world being brought so vividly to life is just, I mean, it's unbelievably exciting. And this woman who is so elegant, so brilliant, Murasaki hated her, perhaps unsurprisingly,
写下了另一部非凡的文学作品。她是整个人类历史上最机智、最优雅、最才华横溢的女性之一。我的意思是，再次阅读它简直是一次无与伦比的体验。那种将一个异世界如此生动地带入现实的感觉——我的意思是，这简直令人难以置信地激动人心。而这位如此优雅、如此才华横溢的女性，紫式部却讨厌她，这或许并不令人意外，
because I think Murasaki, clearly you get sense from her diary that she's much more introverted. And what's fascinating is that the rivalry between these two great literary figures, these two extraordinary women, mirrors a very deep political rivalry at the very heart of the Imperial court, the Heian court. So in the second episode, we will be looking at this rivalry, we'll be looking at the very heart of the Imperial Court, the Heian Court. So in the second episode, we will be looking at this rivalry. We'll be looking at the Heian Court itself, the emperors, the ministers, the extraordinary women who are at this court,
因为我认为从紫式部的日记中可以明显看出她要内向得多。而最令人着迷的是，这两位伟大的文学巨匠、这两位非凡女性之间的竞争，恰好映射了平安朝廷核心一场非常深刻的政治竞争。所以在第二集中，我们将探讨这场竞争，我们将深入探讨平安朝廷本身、天皇、大臣以及身处这个朝廷中的那些非凡女性，
and which, thanks to Murasaki, and thanks to the other extraordinary women in this period who are also writing, I think we know in richer and more intimate detail than any court in history that had existed up until that point. Wonderful. Thank you very much, Tom. So that book is the Pillow Book and we'll be talking about that next time. Tom, thank you so much for that. That was absolutely brilliant. Now, if you want to join our own Imperial Court, you can of course do so by going to therestishistory.com and there you will find all kinds of perfumed
多亏了紫式部，以及多亏了这一时期同样在写作的其他非凡女性，我认为我们对她们的了解，比历史上任何在此之前存在过的宫廷都要丰富、都要更加亲密细致。太棒了，非常感谢你，汤姆。所以那本书就是《枕草子》，我们下次会讨论它。汤姆，非常感谢你带来的精彩分享。这简直太棒了。现在，如果你想加入我们自己的御前朝廷，你当然可以通过访问 therestishistory.com 来做到这一点，在那里你会发现各种熏香
and elegant delights, but you'll also be able to hear that episode right away. So on that bombshell, Tom, aligato and sayonara. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与优雅的乐趣，但你也将能够立即收听那一集节目。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，再见（Arigatou）和再见（Sayonara）。拜拜。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。